[Music]
thank you
Paris was not made in a day
[Music]
all's well that ends well
it is better to prevent than to heal
[Music]
he who takes it slow and steady travels
a long way
[Music]
he who has land has quarrels
there's no substitute for experience
[Music]
all the Glitters Is Not Gold
give some keep the rest
who does not move forward moves backward
[Music]
no one is as deaf as the one who does
not want to listen
the best
[Music]
little by little the bird makes its nest
once the first step is taken There's No
Going Back
whoever laughs last laughs best
every cloud has a silver lining
[Music]
small streams form Great Rivers
but make an omelet without breaking a
few eggs
yeah
nothing should be left to chance
he who steals an egg will steal an ox
[Music]
one always goes back to one's roots
don't try to do two things at once
the vestment does not make the Monk
[Music]
something is unknown now but will become
clear in the future the only way to find
out is to wait and see
each person prioritizes their own
interests and their unique perspective
on life guides how they interact with
others set goals work and live
expect poison from standing water
a badly acquired good never benefits
for the young Hunter an old dog is
needed
[Music]
after the rain good weather
do what you believe is right don't pay
attention to what others have to say
about it
people who are too stubborn or caught up
in their own self-assertions pay no
attention to others advice
[Music]
if youth knew if age could
a door must be open or closed
one should leave nothing to chance
a debt paid is a friend kept
[Music]
don't sell the bears hide before you've
killed the bear
money cannot buy happiness
Only Fools never change their minds
[Music]
we don't teach the old monkey to make a
face
[Music]
only the truth hurts
good
revenge is a dish best served cold
to win without risk is a Triumph without
Glory
[Music]
don't put the cart before the oxen
you will never served better than by
yourself
It Is by forging that you become a
blacksmith
to a valiant heart nothing is impossible
a scolded cat fears cold water
slow and steady wins the race
those who look alike get together
only those who do nothing never fail
a leopard cannot change its spots
when given a horse don't examine its
teeth
you cannot reason with someone who's not
interested in the truth
[Music]
what is bad for some people brings
happiness to others
Fortune Smiles upon the audacious
foreign
truth is not good to tell
[Music]
more is expected of those who have
received more
all grown-ups were one's children but
only few of them remember it
[Music]
become responsible forever for what you
have Tamed
[Music]
I must endure the presence of a few
caterpillars if I wish to become
acquainted with the butterflies
[Music]
the eyes are blind one must look with a
heart
it is the time you have spent on your
rose that makes your rose so valuable
[Music]
the most beautiful things in the world
cannot be seen or touched they are
filled with the heart
to forget a Friend Is Sad not everyone
has had a friend
foreign
[Music]
there is no harm in putting off a piece
of work until another day
[Music]
let your dream devour your life not the
other way around
[Music]
the time for Action is now it's never
too late to start
[Music]
even though human life may be the most
precious thing on earth we behave as if
there was something of higher value
[Music]
it is in your act that you exist not in
your body your act is yourself and there
is no other you
love does not cause suffering what
causes it is the sense of ownership
which is Love's opposite
true happiness comes from the joy of
Deeds well done the zest of creating
things new
[Music]
as for the future your task is not to
foresee it but to enable it
foreign make your life a dream and a
dream a reality
[Music]
you cannot plant an acorn in the morning
and expect that afternoon to sit in the
shade of an oak
[Music]
to be a man is to be responsible to be
ashamed of miseries you did not cause to
be proud of your comrades victories to
be aware
when setting one stone that you are
building a world
it seems that Perfection is attained not
when there is nothing more to add but
when there is nothing more to remove
love does not consist in gazing at each
other
but in looking outward together in the
same direction
each man carries within him the soul of
a poet who died young
true happiness comes from the joy of
Deeds well done the zest of creating new
things
what makes the desert beautiful is that
somewhere it hides a well
a single event can awaken within us a
stranger totally unknown to us
to live is to be slowly born
[Music]
a goal without a plan is just a wish
happiness is like those palaces and
fairy tales whose gates are guarded by
dragons we must fight in order to
conquer it
[Music]
it is much more difficult to judge
oneself than to judge others if you
succeed in judging yourself rightly you
are indeed a man of true wisdom
[Music]
pure love and suspicion cannot dwell
together at the door where the latter
enters the former exits
[Music]
only a man who has failed ultimate
despair is capable of feeling ultimate
Bliss
it is rare that one can see in a little
boy the promise of a man but one can
almost always see in a little girl the
threat of a woman
a person who doubts himself is like a
man who would enlist in the ranks of his
enemies and bear arms against himself
he makes his failure certain by himself
being the first person to be convinced
of it
life is a storm my young friend you will
bask in the sunlight one moment be
shattered on the Rocks the next what
makes you a man is what you do when that
storm comes
[Music]
for all evils there are two remedies
time and silence
[Music]
as a general rule people ask for advice
only in order not to follow it or if
they do follow it in order to have
someone to blame for giving it
[Music]
when one doesn't have the things that
one loves one must love what one has
[Music]
there are two ways of seeing with the
body and with the soul the body's sight
can sometimes forget
but the soul remembers forever
real love begins where nothing is
expected in return
[Music]
always in a hurry to be happy
for when we have suffered a long time we
have great difficulty in believing and
good fortune
[Music]
human with
summed up in two words wait and Hope
[Music]
women are never so strong as after their
defeat
[Music]
once work may be finished someday but
one's education never
foreign
[Music]